what i like about baklava is there's
absolutely a sweetness but you also have
this rich nut filling to kind of balance
it out hi i'm sarah and today i'm going
to be showing you how to make baklava
both of my parents are egyptian so today
the baklava i'm going to make is the
baklava that i grew up with
i grew up with a baklava that's got a
little bit of sweetness to it but
there's a nice crispness to it so we
have
lots of layers of flaky filado all
different different kinds but this is
what i grew up with and what feels
nostalgic for me
filido is a very thin thin thin delicate
pastry sheet so when you buy it it's
pre-formed in sheets it's actually
really important that you're able to
thaw it out overnight and then let it
sit at room temperature if you're buying
it frozen and that'll help allow the
sheets to fully defrost and not stick
together when you're taking it out of
the package my mom would always tell me
that when you're first taking the
philadel out of the package the first
couple sheets that you're going to be
working with are going to tend to be the
driest ones so it's not unusual for you
have to like potentially throw out first
couple sheets um you might also find
some sheets that are broken or a little
bit hard to manage but once you start to
get a little bit further into the
package the phyllo dough will become a
little bit easier to work with when
you're doing this recipe ideally you're
going to have a single shape but if you
end up using multiple sheets of phyllo
dough at the same time that's going to
be okay it might feel a little bit
delicate or fragile when you're first
working with it but that's why you want
to brush it with butter and when you
brush it with butter that's going to
soften it up and then allow it to roll
really well when you're using a filling
so there's actually different types of
filaro and when you're purchasing
philadel if it's for something like
desserts a lot of times you'll actually
see a number scale on field oh when
you're looking to make baklava something
that's going to be light and flaky
you're going to try to get a filo though
that's a number four or a number seven
when you get into
seven or ten you're going to be looking
at philadelph that's going to be heavier
consistency and that's typically for
things that are going to have either a
heavier or sometimes a wet feeling
baklava is because it's really common
you'll see it as an everyday kind of
dessert but it also tends to be a
special occasion one too so in a lot of
middle eastern culture baklava tends to
be a dessert that you see a lot during
ramadan so for that reason too baklava
has a special place in my heart
ramadan's a holiday where you're fasting
from sunrise to sunset so when you're
able to break fast and have a meal with
friends or family the meals that you eat
have a special significance to them and
it's something that you look forward to
all day so a lot of times having that
nice sweetness of like a nice dessert at
the end of the day makes it really
special
oh yes
[Music]
you